la présidentielle approche et avec elle
les prédictions de madame irma et les
uns fox de bonimenteur pullulent dans un
bruit de lavabos qui se vide la dernière
en date selon l'ops le kremlin vote
zemmour même pas au conditionnel mais
aussi bien les analyses des géostratège
proche du kremlin que la tonalité de la
presse contrôlée par le pouvoir russe
laisse peu de doute sur le choix d'un
pouvoir russe qui commençaient à
désespérer de marine le pen pour poutine
l'espoir c'est zemmour est maintenant
dans notre grand horoscope je vous
propose de passer aux prévisions des
capricornes pourquoi l'homme s'est-il
certain que le kremlin votre humour le
journaliste s'appuie sur un obscur
médias qui dénaturent l'analyse d'une
parlementaire et les nappes à nina issu
du parti au pouvoir russie unie
le tout sur le blog d'un crime tant que
personne ne connaît et les nappes à nina
parlerai au nom de vladimir poutine
selon l'ops voilà deux ans elle a créé
un film d'un roux strates qualifié par
l'ops de boîte à outils du kremlin en
réalité sur le site de rousse strates et
n'a pas nina se contente de décrire le
chroniqueur français et ses idées et
elle conclut son article par une
précaution verbale dans le cas d'une
victoire du polémiste il est possible
que l'on assiste à une alliance de
moscou paris et berlin qui affrontera
les anglo saxons emmenée par les états
unis et la grande bretagne on est loin
de l'annoncé d'un soutien de vladimir
poutine mais penchons nous sur cette
influence intake les articles du site
affiche entre 38 et 150 vu chacun dans
sa version anglaise avec une moyenne de
quelques milliers de vues sur les
articles écrits en russe comme un bon
blog sur les selle de cheval ou les
fourchettes à huîtres en comparaison le
monde affiche plus de 300 millions de
pages vues en septembre 2021 cette
supposée boîte à outils du kremlin
semble un peu rouillé l'autre source de
l'ops dans ce dossier et le media desk
russie qui lui aussi réplique l'article
2 roues strates entre autres
élucubrations on apprend qu'eric zemmour
pourrait entamer une guerre civile
appelons hollywood ils pourraient même
demander aux forces russes de faire de
l'ordre en france face à une révolte des
banlieues consécutives à ces mesures
contre l'immigration
descriptif est dirigée par galia
ackerman qui demandait qu'on refuse la
liste de diffusion rt france et par le
haut fonctionnaire nicolas tenzer dans
la rue sauf il y n'a d'égal que l'amour
qu'il porte à rt france un organe de
propagande dépendant du kremlin n'est
pas un organe de presse ceux qui
acceptent de parler sur russia today
sont soit des complices du régime et
donc de ces crimes soient des personnes
qu'ils consentent implicitement être
manipulé par lui tout cela pourrait
n'être que comique si c'est le fadaises
n'avait pas été immédiatement relayée
dans des articles du monde entier de
l'australie à la grande bretagne en
passant par la pologne et aussi par la
députée européenne nathalie l'oiseau pas
de doute moscou vote et moore mais aussi
encore un peu le pen aucun doute a
contrario des chercheurs sur la
stratégie d'influencé informationnel
russe en france pourtant très critique
du kremlin honteux même relevé l'inanité
de l'article de l'ops bon je vais
reprendre point par point ce qui ne va
pas dans cet article et la liste est
longue ça me met en rogne carey dax chef
puisse laisser publier ce genre de chose
d'autant plus dans ce contexte
préélectoral ils font le jeu du pouvoir
russe qui doit se réjouir d'avancé de
voir son nombre planer sur la campagne
pour 3000 signes publié par un think
tank inconnu je vois déjà la vidéo
triomphante de rt france qui va suivre
tout content qu'on parle d'eux alors oui
voilà la vidéo mais nous ne sommes pas
particulièrement ravi que l'on parle de
nous de plus en tant que média de
propagande russe à destination de
l'étranger selon la logique du
journaliste de l'ops puisque eric
zemmour serait le candidat de vladimir
poutine nous devrions donc déroulé le
tapis rouge au chroniqueur mais ce sont
les médias français qui s'en charge avec
une certaine insistance seul marianne et
les échos cite son nom - que nous
rappelons avant que d'autres médias si m
kurt et france n'est pas partisane et
n'appuie aucun candidat dans l'hexagone
la chaîne se fera le relais de tous les
participants à la présidentielle quel
que soit leur bord politique comme
durant chaque élection et promis on ne
vous dira pas l'horoscope